we are delivering today the iPad the new
iMac the iPod my photo MacBook Air
iTunes the revolutionary he was one of
the most creative and daring CEOs a
global icon who shaped the worlds of
technology and media for over 30 years
computers music movies and mobile phones
were transformed by Apple's Steve Jobs
he was a brilliant visionary few
executives in history suffered such
painful setbacks it looked like Jobs was
was washed-up it was a total has been or
enjoyed as much success as Steve came
back and began what I think is the
greatest turnaround in the history of
corporate America
a very remarkable man extremely smart a
spellbinding mesmerizing leader of
people jobs went from having nearly
blown this amazing fortune and
bankrupted himself to a rising as a
billionaire with a brilliant future
Steve Jobs was a true son of Silicon
Valley born in 1955 in San Francisco he
was raised in its freewheeling culture
of experimentation and innovation
Alan Gorch Minh is an author who has
written extensively about Jobs and Apple
Steve Jobs from going back to when he
was a teenager was very influenced by
the 1960s 1970s counterculture you know
he loved the Beatles he loved Bob Dylan
he enrolled in Oregon's Reed College but
dropped out to travel after just one
semester Robert X cringe Lee was Apple
Computer employee number 12 but I met
him he was I think nineteen years old he
had hair down to his waist and he only
ate fruit and he would see how clearly
hippy when Jobs returned to his
childhood home in California he became
interested in what was then an entirely
new concept the personal computer he
joined meetings of the homebrew Computer
Club with a man who would become his
partner in founding Apple Computer Steve
Wozniak people getting up these
computers are gonna revolutionize life
and I felt like oh my god I'm a part of
this huge revolution that we're talking
about everybody's gonna have a computer
in the home and nobody in the outside
world believes us projects that I would
design and build very frequently Steve
would say he knew how to sell it
Jobs and Wozniak took time off their day
jobs to set up shop in the family garage
in Los Altos we didn't have a telephone
to phone the computer stores in the
garage that was in Steve's bedroom the
team's first computer the Apple one
as the tech industry in Silicon Valley
took off jobs saw opportunity the
penalty for failure for going and trying
to start a company in this valley is
non-existent there really isn't the
penalty for failure either
psychologically or economically in the
sense that if you have a good idea and
you go go out to start your own company
even if you fail you're generally
considered worth more to the company you
left because you've gained all this
valuable experience in many disciplines
to bring their ideas to life the Apple
team needed capital jobs convinced angel
investor Mike Markkula to invest around
$90,000 and a line of credit in the
fledgling company it was exactly what
they needed to create their new computer
the Apple to what was revolutionary
about the Apple 2 was its use of color
the fact it had a built-in keyboard and
it was the first one to look like a
consumer device and so it was a huge
success you know it was astounding
success right from the beginning Steve
came to me one day and he said you
realize our stock is worth more than our
parents have been in their lifetime
I was done what the heck how can you
have so much and then six months later
you have 10 times more they were the
stars of Silicon Valley and the cover
boys for a new industry Michael Moritz
is a former Time magazine reporter and a
legendary Silicon Valley venture
capitalist there's always that sense of
anxiety and tension associated with the
question how can we possibly follow this
in 1979 in a stock deal reportedly worth
1 million dollars Steve Jobs was allowed
access to Xerox PARC the company's famed
research in development laboratory jobs
and his team saw the future here the way
computers would be used including the
use of graphics and a small device that
had not yet been revealed to the outside
world a mouse
you'd see two programs at once if I was
stunned they see three programs at once
and I oh my god
once you have this machine you're never
gonna want to go back it's a one-way
door you computers are gonna be this way
and you'll never go back
Leander kini is the editor of the blog
cult of Mack and the author of the book
inside Steve's brain Xerox had invented
the entire paradigm of modern computing
but they had no idea what they were
sitting on but jobs did he wanted to
bring the graphical user interface to
Apple computer but first he had to deal
with a power shift going on inside Apple
the Apple board of directors wanted an
experienced executive to be president of
the company Jobs interviewed dozens of
candidates before he focused on someone
from outside the tech world Pepsi CEO
John Sculley Steve in those days he had
long black hair and very piercing
Palmetto berry eyes he looked down at
his running shoes and then he looked up
at me and he said do you want to sell
sugar water for the rest of your life or
do you want to come with me and change
the world and it was like someone just
knocked the wind out of my stomach the
few weeks later I was working at Apple
for Apple Computer to thrive they also
needed another successful product Jobs
thought he had it in a powerful business
computer called the Lisa but the Apple
Board of Directors refused to give him
the project Jobs threw himself into
another project the Macintosh
he felt this would break open the market
or rather to characterize Steve's brain
properly or rather the market ought to
break open you know if the market had
any sense he set up shop in an outlying
building in the Apple complex and his
intense drive began to take its toll on
the Mac team people would bring him work
to look at it would be one o'clock in
the morning sometime Steve said I'm not
gonna look at it and it will Steve I've
worked on this thing for 25 hours he
said I know but it's not good enough you
know go back and work on it some more
some of them just wound up just quitting
and discussed some of them wound up
saying they'd never work for Steve again
they just couldn't when the exhausted
team finished they had a revolutionary
new computer many of us have been
working on Macintosh for over two years
now
and it has turned out insanely great Guy
Kawasaki was the software evangelist on
the original Mac in like 60 seconds
after I saw the demo of Macintosh I was
so cool angel started to sing I mean it
was a beautiful experience this was
supposed to be the computer that tamed
the complexity of everything associated
with world of computing to make it
available as Steve would say for mere
mortals with his intuitive marketing
sense Jobs unveiled the Mac with a
spellbinding commercial aimed at IBM the
leader in
aired nationally only once on Super Bowl
Sunday in January of 1984 but the impact
was explosive we estimated we got 45
million dollars of free publicity of it
being run over and over again by
television networks all over the world
because no one had ever seen a
commercial like this before but the
excitement surrounding the Mac launch
didn't translate into sales and jobs is
standing at Apple became the big
question he ran amok at Apple he cost
the company a lot of money so Steve was
considered to be wasteful he was
considered to be self-indulgent he was
the largest shareholder but also a kind
of a brat the thinking was well
Macintosh should not penetrate a
business we need a more mature
leadership some adult supervision to run
the company
by 1985 tension at Apple rose as an
internal power struggle threatened to
tear the company apart
I said Steven we're a public company and
I have to tell the board where we are in
terms of inventory in terms of sales
performance and we're in trouble when
hit reached the point where he
identified skully as a rival
he decided had to take scollay out and
much to Steve's surprise the board sided
with Scully the knee-jerk reaction of
conventional people is to elbow what
they see as disruptive forces aside and
Steve the co-founder of Apple was
unchivalrous Lee rushing to the exit hey
BAM fired almost destroyed him they
threw him out of his own company and he
thought it was unbelievable jobs quickly
regrouped taking five top managers to
start a computer company called next
there were all kinds of ideas and it
turned out that he wanted to go back and
once again create the most insanely
great computer something that would help
change the world
very modest ambitions the company
struggled to find a market for its
expensive new computer jobs faced a
tough choice abandon the computer or
face bankruptcy it was a big deal when
they realized that very few people were
buying their hardware but it turned out
that their software was just
breathtaking
the decision ditched the highly designed
computer and focus instead on selling
what makes it run the company's elegant
operating system
I think that period during which he
wandered in the wilderness was a period
full of adversity and I think people
come back from adversity if they can
return from adversity they come back
harder sharper and far more geared for
battle in a 2005 commencement address at
Stanford University Steve Jobs revealed
for the first time some personal details
about his early life my biological
mother was a young unwed graduate
student and she decided to put me up for
adoption my biological mother found out
later that my mother had never graduated
from college and that my father had
never graduated from high school she
refused to sign the final adoption
papers she only relented a few months
later when my parents promised that I
would go to college this was the start
in my life he was raised by parents who
adopted him they were blue-collar
salt-of-the-earth people they were good
parents and but they weren't
intellectuals later in life he
discovered that his biological parents
weren't intellectuals and his biological
sister she turned out to be a brilliant
novelist Mona Simpson in 1991 at age 36
Jobs started his own family when he
married Laurene Powell they had three
children in addition to his daughter
from a previous relationship Jobs called
these years after Apple his most
creative and personally fulfilling his
professional life was also changing
dramatically right after his ouster from
Apple Jobs bought a company from Lucas
Films that would become a household name
this little animation company called
pixel he hired John Lasseter an animator
from Disney their goal was to create
fully computer animated feature films
and Hollywood was interested Pixar made
a deal with Disney to work together to
make a toy story I actually had made the
deal with him at the time he came into
the movie businesses instincts were
impeccable put his money up his own
personal money he was on the line
in 1995 jobs investment in Pixar was
about to pay off in a big way I am Buzz
Lightyear I come in peace oh I'm so glad
you're not a dinosaur Toy Story Pixar's
first feature film was a blockbuster and
became 1995's highest-grossing u.s.
movie Pixar really created probably the
most successful genre in the movie
business today which is CG animation
when Pixar went public
Steve Jobs became a billionaire
it had been more than 10 years since
Steve Jobs had been fired from Apple and
the drama in turmoil at the company
continued to get worse after Steve left
the company it lost its compass lost its
mission
it lost its founding spirit its products
got old and stale and during that whole
period Microsoft had gotten stronger and
strong computers running Windows
accounted for nearly 80 percent of the
market Apple's market share could not
break 11% and their ousted co-founder
was sitting on an operating system that
could save them they wanted next
operating system in an ironic and
stunning turn of events Apple Computer
bought next for over 400 million dollars
we're gonna be building our next
generation operating system on next
technology selling next Davalos sheer
genius
you just have to say Wow Steve Jobs
returned to the company he helped create
and became interim CEO and so that began
what I think is the greatest turnaround
in the history of corporate America
it was his finest hour really and he he
hauled Assam and brought things back
together again around a cohesive vision
because he came in as the Rainmaker he
called a big meeting in this big meeting
room and he says you know what's wrong
with this company and everyone's too
scared to answer no one say anything
because the products suck they've got no
sex in him the comeback included a
remarkable announcement Bill Gates who
had long been considered job's main
rival would invest in Apple Computer
Microsoft invested $150 in Apple to help
save the day that must have been the low
point for Apple I happen to have a
special guest with me today via
satellite downlink and if we could get
him up on the stage right now
very excited about the new release we're
building this is called Mac office 98
once back at Apple jobs characteristic
Flair for marketing came back in full
force Ken Siegel worked with jobs on a
breakthrough advertising campaign that
defined their new direction here's to
the crazy ones The Misfits the rebels
the troublemakers the round pegs in the
square holes think different became the
line that launched apples rebirth Steve
was aware of every detail I mean
literally every word every image one of
the reasons why I thought the words were
so perfect is I think you literally
could have hung a sign that said think
different in the garage when Wozniak and
jobs created their company it would have
been appropriate then you know as it is
today but the company was still in
trouble and needed a hit it found it in
a redesign of the bulky beige box there
was a kind of a gasp from around the
room because keep in mind that no
computer had ever looked anything like
that it was transparent you can see the
guts of it it looked like came out of
the Jetsons or something the iMac was an
astounding success the thing was the
biggest selling computer of all time six
million units sold and it really sort of
set the stage for Apple's comeback if I
hadn't been ahead Apple when Steve Jobs
would be history it gave them enough
money and enough momentum you know to
start coming out with other products
soon after he saw the future and it was
not a personal computer this is the best
thing I think we've ever done in October
2001 Jobs unveiled something that even
for Apple was groundbreaking
the iPod went from concept to market in
about eight months but the iPod itself
was only one part of a much bigger plan
I think the genius of the iPod was
iTunes not iPod Jobs was going after a
music business under siege by piracy and
file-sharing
Larry Ken's will and other music
executives were called up to Apple's
Cupertino offices to negotiate terms
that would define the future of the
music industry the negotiation was
classic Steve Jobs he simply said if I
can't sell if a $0.99 on my store I am
not selling it that's it no discussion
in business you used to a lot of
give-and-take that's not apples way
apples ways they get what they want when
iTunes became available on Windows as
well as Macs the music industry realized
just who had a gold record a complete
monopoly retail online both Apple and
the music business have come out ahead
because of Apple's entry but Apple has
made a whole lot more money because
they're selling hardware for hundreds of
dollars in the music business is selling
ninety nights and products over 350
million iPods have been sold since its
release in October of 2001 the company's
product lodges became huge events
anticipation and speculation grew to a
fever pitch with every new product
we went into the holiday quarter with
the best lineup of music players on the
planets we believe that the personal
computer is undergoing a rapid evolution
to be the center of our digital lives
and we have never been more excited
about this jobs signature approach is
known as the reality distortion field
the reality distortion field is where he
says and it only costs eighteen hundred
dollars and people applaud and when they
get home they say yeah but the computer
that I have now cost $900 why is it good
that it only costs $1,800 and worse
still why did I buy one on the way out
you're not talking about numbers you're
not talking about you know anything
rational you're talking about emotional
in the summer of 2004 Apple Computer was
thriving but its leader was not Jobs
revealed in an employee email that he
had been diagnosed with what he said was
a treatable form of pancreatic cancer he
wrote that he underwent successful
surgery for the deadly disease and
expected a full recovery
you
in 2007 after a frightening health scare
Steve Jobs was back on stage for one of
the most important launches in Apple's
history it was a product Apple had been
secretly developing for years is a
revolutionary there was so much buzz
about that there was estimated to be
worth 400 million dollars that's all you
could read about from October 2 through
to January but there wasn't a goat
farmer in Afghanistan that hadn't heard
about the iPhone it was far more than a
phone this is handheld computing a year
later at an iPhone event in June of 2008
Jobs was noticeably thinner and frail
speculation spread that the cancer he
was treated for four years earlier had
returned jobs jokingly shrugged off the
rumors but after missing his first
Macworld since his return he finally
disclosed that his health problems were
more complex and announced a medical
leave of absence day-to-day operations
were turned over to Apple's chief
operating officer Tim Cook after a liver
transplant in September 2009 Jobs
returned in his trademark outfit to his
familiar mark on stage so I now have the
liver of a mid-20s person who died in a
car crash and was generous enough to
donate their organs and I wouldn't be
here without such generosity I'm
vertical I'm back at Apple loving every
day of it the next year he revealed yet
another extraordinary device with his
typically less than subtle script it's
phenomenal fantastic the best device
I've ever seen and why
to show it to you today for the first
time and we'll call it the iPad
it was another giant success for jobs
but the celebration was short-lived
in January 2011 with Apple surging to
all-time highs Steve Jobs announced his
third and final medical leave
he finally encountered a foe he could
not outrun true to form Jobs had
anticipated this moment at Stanford in
2005 and what some now consider one of
the best commencement addresses of all
time don't let the noise of others
opinions drown out your own inner voice
and most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become everything else is secondary
ever a child of the 60s he signed off
with words from a favorite source the
Whole Earth Catalog stay hungry stay
foolish
thank you all very much song for me I'm
not sleepy and there's no place I'm
going to Steve Jobs died on October 5th
2011 at his home in Palo Alto he was 56
at the time of his death Apple Inc was
the most valuable company in crown of
creation
so you could say well what's the big
deal anybody could have done the
Macintosh anybody had done the iPhone
anybody could have built-in CD ROMs into
computers anybody could have put
firewire anybody could have done any of
this the reality is nobody else did it
and so that's the genius of Steve Jobs
today on til tomorrow
I think visionary is one of those words
that gets abused and particularly in
Silicon Valley when anyone wearing
spectacles can recall the visionary
steve is one of the very few people I
think they're probably only a handful of
people in Silicon Valley since World War
two maybe you can count them on the
fingers of one hand who deserve that
moniker steve is one of them
you